Allow me to introduce myself. My name is Hippocrates. I'm a natural
philosopher from over 2400 years ago,
and I've studied the mechanisms of inheritance.
>> Okay, well lay it on us.
>> It's called Blended Inheritance.
>> Well, what's Blended Inheritance?
>> Blended Inheritance is the idea that
one particular trait in an offspring came
from one of the parents directly or is a mix of the parents traits.
>> But how do you think that works, exactly? I'm not exactly sure,
but I've seen this fluid that comes from the
male reproductive organ, and I think females probably have something
similiar. My theory is that it's a mix based
on the battle of fluids between the male and female.
>> Hm, well I'm pretty sure you're right about the male reproductive fluid.
>> But I think you're a little behind the times on the female fluid.
>> My theory is that these fluids are actually an
amalgamation of fluids from throughout the whole body. Each responsible
for forming that particular part. The fluid from the toes
is responsible for forming the toes, and the fluid from
the eyes is responsible for forming more eyes, and so
on. At conception, a battle of fluid takes place, and the
child will resemble aspects of whichever fluid wins that battle;
one or the other parents, or a mix of both. Ok.
I mean, even though we know a lot more about
how reproduction works now, your idea of blended inheritance does sound
kind of reasonable.
>> But, I can think of an example that breaks the rule of inheritance. Which
of the following scenarios do you think shows
that Hippocrates's blending model doesn't explain every trait?